Hi. We are going to check on some
experiments. We're going to launch some
sweeps. Whenever Spencer is
around, we will um do some stuff on GPU
drive. We will go from
there. Discord needs to update. One
second.
All
right, let's just see uh when he is
around so we will be able to get to work
on that
today built
six.
support. Perfect.
So Spencer will be around in, you know,
whenever and we will look at the uh
driving simulator stuff and get those
experiments working. Uh I think what
we're going to do in the meantime is
we're going to look at the maze
experiments from earlier today and uh
also
the uh the breakout experiments. We're
going to launch some new hyperparam
sweeps. We're going to figure out a few
small details there. That should have us
in a spot where we have some really
really solid models. uh that we can now
start using those hyperparameters on
other
environments. We can probably start
hyperparam sweeping neural MMO and
really optimizing that. Yeah, lots and
lots of good things coming here. And one
message real
Okay. So, where we left this off, uh, we
were looking at these experiments over
here. Where'd it
go? All right. So, we got
these and we have the breakout graphs.
These are super simple. But we also have
this. This is best performance ever seen
on uh maze solving. In fact, why don't
we watch this policy real
policy. This is an incredibly difficult
environment for reinforcement learning.
Uh it's just seeing a little tiny window
around itself and it has to figure out
how to do this whole maze. Uh we have
this policy here. So what you're seeing
now, even though this particular
instance it's not doing so well, you see
how it's actually like backtracking
somewhat coherently. Yeah, that's not a
thing that RL typically learns. And if
you look at most works that do mazes
with RL, they do little tiny mazes and
then they come up with a bunch of really
specific methods for solving mazes uh
just mazes or whatever or like they hack
additional exploration things onto it.
Uh we didn't do any of that and this
kind of just does stuff. You can see
it's exploring like pretty different
sections of this maze. It's actually
gotten pretty close
now. You know, it just needs to get this
last section here. This is a very hard
maze.
Oh, come on,
Puffer. I'd be very impressed if it
solves this one. This one's really hard.
Like, look at the length of the path
here. Oh, yeah. Yeah, it's like all the
way winding around this way. The very
hard maze and it's very
close. I don't know why it's stuck on
this corner here. I think that this will
just be improved when we tune the policy
generally. These little ones though, you
can see it's like, yeah, no big deal. It
just solves them,
harder. See, like that was a big maze
where the optimal path wasn't that hard.
The ones where it's really hard though,
it's like you're not solving that with
anything else in
RL. Okay, so this is what we have at the
moment on this.
Um, I'm trying to think where we go from
here. There are a few little bits of
analysis I want to still do.
So, we
have these hypers over here. This is
from the optimized
run. I probably do want to rerun this
sweep with like slightly better
args. I do want to also compare though
the default hypers from before the
sweep, the hypers we got after. First
let's do the breakout
ones. So on breakout
here Adam beta 1 got increased from 0.9
to.99. That's a big change. Beta 2 got
dropped no increased again an
extra
n. Epsilon is just always super low. We
didn't sweep batch size or anything. I
think entropy yeah entropy got
increased.
Lambda stayed the
same. Gamma got decreased. Actually in
line with what I would
expect. Uh learning rate I believe got
doubled because mini batch size also got
doubled. That's
sensible. Max grad norm got tripled.
Okay. And then the value function
coefficient was high before and is still
high now. Okay. So we have some changes
here.
Um, not a huge number of changes, but we
definitely have some
changes. I think what we're going to do
is we are going to rerun the sweeps with
uh some changes to the ranges over which
we're allowed to
sweep. I think we will probably rerun
both breakout and
uh and
mazes. The breakout sweep will be done
later today. It's quite quick. The maze
sweep will take longer.
So then later once we're done with the
maze sweep, we will start sweeping some
other environments such as GPU drive or
uh Impulse Wars or any of those because
we're starting to actually get to where
we can really use this stuff
effectively. So few things to
start before I
have I think you generally want to have
a few random
runs. Yeah, I think you generally do
want to have um a few random runs
defaults. Maybe if you don't have a
search center to seed
with, maybe then it makes sense.
I don't know why I stopped doing uh
audio books. I don't know.
year. I guess we don't really need to do
anything with this if
um it just seems really weird to me to
rely on random
search for much of anything.
Like you have 20 dimensional space and
you just pick five random points. Like
that scales
way. Yeah, just do it this way. And you
have to have like at least something
that kind of trains to start with.
That's no
problem. Okay. So now the main thing
that we need to do
then we need to add um add some defaults
in here.
coefficient train clip
coefficient be
uniform can't be zero.
Yes, it technically could be, but that'd
be really weird.
What's like a reasonable
max?
One and then we set mean at
0.1 makes sense as a
uniform. I think this makes sense as a a
uniform. I mean, everything you do with
this, right, it makes it harder to
learn,
but value function clip coefficient can
be way higher though,
right? Be like five max or
something. Or do we also set this to one
max?
max. These are both at um 0.1 mean
though the
sense? The thing is it's like it's
tricky because it's a discrete variable.
If I just don't do this for now, we just
keep it at one update epoch,
this. Are there any other prams we
should sweep? Two. Three, four,
five, six. Oh, this should not
be. This should be like log or
something,
Yeah. One, two, three, four, five, six,
eight.
Looks like we'll do some GPU drive
stuff. Let me see if I can at least kick
off these
experiments while
uh he gets
here. Think we can just launch him.
This should be way longer though, right?
This should be
maybe. Probably not even
enough. I don't want it to go like
crazy, though.
Hey, Spencer.
Hey. How's it going?
I'm pretty good.
Um, we're doing quite well here. The
sweeps were pretty nice overnight.
Nice address. I'm trying to get a clean
version into release right now. I can
help with that.
Um, when I was trying to do like just an
a down and dirty just kind of like
pulling things from release into mine, I
ran into a kind of an odd error where I
was looking for an underscore C package.
I don't know if that's something you're
Yeah. Oops.
I have to I Yeah, I have to show you.
There's There's a jank way you have to
build the new release stuff. My bad. I
forgot to tell you about that.
No problem. Uh, I think the cleanest way
to go about this would be for me to just
make a new branch from release and then
just start dropping the the files I had
from the puffer drive branch just
directly from like the four files it is
from the in the GPU drive. Uh, just like
check out what you would do is you would
just make why you don't want to just
merge it into the release branch. Um
because the it seems like when I was
looking at the PR differences when uh I
was going to make a PR with just like
kind of pulling in release, it had like
50 files that were changed. Yeah. But it
should none of it should really affect
you,
right? But it may affect the other
release things. No. From just maybe
things. No, not if you just add if
you're just adding in GPU drive as an
end, it
won't. And also the release branch is
like the branch that I'm working on for
the release. It's not like it is the
current release, right? Sure. It's Yeah,
I'd rather just have this thing like up
to date because like my plan is to work
more closely with you on this since you
have more time. So, we just like, you
know, nail this thing and we get this to
NYU before like everybody's fully gone
and you know, like we just Yeah. Like we
get the thing going quick. Basically,
whenever anything is working fully in
release, like dev goes fast because I
can test my latest stuff on it by
default. And whenever it doesn't, it's
slow.
Okay, then.
Um, yeah, I mean, there's just a bunch
of files you change that I have not
touched. So, I'm just going to kind of
assume that these are not fine. I'll
show you how to build them then with um
stuff in here.
Let me just triple check that it has the
right thing.
Okay. All right. PRing buffer drive into
the release
branch. And I am also uh I'm just
launching some new sweeps for us real
quick.
I'm like fine-tuning the uh the sweep
system for us so like it really nails
everything. We got some pretty cool
results on mazes
Okay.
Yeah. Did you just push something to
release? Oh, I'm always pushing stuff to
release.
Okay. Hold up. Like Yeah, of course. I
pushed like stuff like five times in the
last few minutes.
Okay. Well, I'm trying to sync my fork
of release into yours. I mean to make
sure that I have Well, I didn't say I
was going to make it easy on you.
All right. Don't Don't push something
for like minutes. Okay. Let me in your
damn thing.
I wasn't actually trying to just mess
with that. I just happened to be setting
up hyperparam sweeps and needed to sync
Thanks.
All right. Have our sweeps
done. Those are all
launched. The latest configs. Expect
great things from them.
Um, soon as you have that done, I will
merge things. We should be good to
[Music]
go. Okay, so that merge should be in
here. So now if I go to the
PRs, I think it should just
automatically update my PR with the
thing I just did.
You know, one crazy thing
uh since starting Puffer is a lot of my
spam has now turned into like marketing
for founders.
So, I get I get DMs like, "Hey, you want
to pay us to help us help us get you
into the news?" It's like, "Can I pay
you to like keep us out of the news?"
Oh. Have you gotten the author spams
where they're like, "Can I can I write a
book about you?"
No, I don't get those. I get like, "Can
you like submit your paper to this like
crap predatory conference?"
What file did I just get to make sure
this is
I await PR.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Just trying to make sure I don't nuke
your code base. I mean, I do it
constantly.
I do have a PR up. We are literally two
stars off of
2K. Come on. There at least two people
watching this who have not started the
repo. Start the
repo. It's
free. All right. There's a buffer drive
PR
open to merge my puffer drive from my
somebody opened of Intel.
Yeah, I saw that request earlier. I
don't know what it was for.
Is this an actual person or is this like
I'm starting to suspect that there are
um
way
but like the thing is I I didn't type
this anywhere. So that means that they
have bots doing
Yeah, they're doing like captioning
followed by this stuff.
aggressive. I mean,
like this one for
instance.
Possibly. There are a lot of like
coherent but like very random off-topic
things.
Oh, you did open the PR. Yeah. Is this
ready to be merged? It should be. Oh, I
thought you were still doing it.
Okay. Merge into
release. 26 file
changes. Let me see what you
did. 26 files is
I was telling you it's a lot. But like
there's Connect 4 stuff in here.
Are these fixes for things? That's why I
was saying cuz this this is stuff that
just came in from from
dev. So I can make a cleaner one with
just GPU drive stuff. Oh yeah, that's
Yeah, that was the idea because like
there's a whole bunch of Connect 4 stuff
in here.
That's that's what I was trying to say,
but you were like just just nuke it. So
yeah. No, I meant like just give me the
the GPU drive files and just shove them
to dev. Okay, that's what I'm going to
do. It shouldn't be 26 files. Like you
shouldn't need to change. No, it should
be like four.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I I guess that was not
clear. So yes, that is what I
I'm going to give you a minute to do
that. I will be right back. Yeah.
I'm getting through one file right now.
I'm doing them all one at a time.
I'm doing this via the
box right now.
So like copy pasting files. Yep.
Have you seen
um Tyler slash big cat slash whatever
the heck his other username is around in
the discord or wherever?
Um was he the circuit guy or was he he
does uh pulse power. He's like
He's uh yeah, he does like pulse power
stuff. Um and he's trying to do RL
things as well. And
apparently he's gotten himself uh an
intern who wants to do RL drone things
over the summer. Oh,
cool. So, if you're looking
to set stuff up in that space and have
some help with it.
Yep.
I outsource things to you and you
outsource things further on.
Yeah, let me uh let me work on that.
If you didn't do it already, I would
make sure just to reject that uh PR, the
previous one.
This
whatever. I think the one is 217 or
something like that. The most whatever
that one was. Okay. The one that had
like all the file changes.
Oh, hold up. You're going to
need What else are you going to
need? Oh, how am I going to get these
things into you?
Yeah. I'm just thinking it was the
easiest way to get the GB files over
from the other branch. GLB
the model files for the cars.
Well, certainly providing me ample time
for exercise.
Oh, chill.
I'm typing at light speed.
I'm not complaining.
It used to be I'd have to just sit
there, but now I have all sorts of fun
things. All right, now I got the car
models over. Let me pull up the Now, let
me make the
changes. Okay, I did that into the
release branch. All right. Lean puffer
drive Python file.
It should have four major files and then
six car models.
Perfect.
Um, when I one Yeah. Well, first I guess
I want to know how do you set up your
All right, let me show you. It's kind of
dumb.
It's kind of real
dumb. The first thing we do, let's build
your GPU drive
thing, which
is Syon extensions. Yeah, it should be
Syon.
It's just called
extensions. So we go to ext modules and
build
extensions. Yes.
Okay. That builds GPU
drive. Okay. So that builds correctly.
Yeah. It didn't look like any errors
came up. Mhm. And now what we have to do
Whoops.
is we have to
do forch extensions with this build
command.
So the same build command this command
class build has to get uncommented.
Oh, okay. It's annoying cuz
like there's a bunch of stuff I have to
do to make this not as to set
up.
Basically, essentially, Python tooling
is just terrible.
Oh, it might be on uh performance right
now, not demo.
Six could be
faster. There we
are. GPU drive is got to be puffer drive
or something because it's not on a GPU
anymore.
Yeah,
buffer drive.
Should probably pick a different map as
the map it just spawns in. Yeah, wrecks
itself. But
I thought these were like It's not
perfect,
but we zoom out. I don't think they're
like that
noticeable. All right. All right. So,
now that you have that done, uh, one
thing I noticed when I tried to do the
latest run after our work yesterday was
it just doesn't work at
all. Even though I just pulled it
in to the latest one we had with the
latest config
changes, the value loss was like spiking
to like infinity.
So, when you did what then? The value
loss spikes to infinity. um when I just
pulled from last night's
work and then copied over the
uh
config like I wasn't able to match the
point4 that I had from yesterday.
See this config
Don't have a sweep thing defined in
here. Oh, it's supposed to be I didn't
push a config file.
Upper G drive.
We do Horizon
91. And what did we say we were going to
do? Uh, if you look in the general chat,
you you copied it from last night. Okay.
So, let's just
that. Um, let's see what else would you
not have in the release branch.
You're not going to have all the
binaries, I don't think. What binaries?
Like all the maps. Oh, yeah. How we get
um You got to go
to Let me go to the GPU drive.
Well, I I have them on the same machine
from anyways, right?
Did they get wiped from the being on
this branch? They're not tracked by yet.
Is the eight still hardcoded in there?
It shouldn't be. No, it should just be
the 582 now or whatever it
is. I took that out.
out. Okay, so the VMs has a ton of
agents for some weird reason.
Okay. 1,900 agents in one file for 64
maps. That's high, right? For it should
be 75 maps, but I don't know if you just
set it at 64. Yeah, I did. But this is
too big. Yeah, it should be nowhere near
that high. Okay, so um
M 256 M is high, right? Yes, it is. That
would be more appropriate if it was 256.
Oh,
64. All these rewards are also screwy.
They should be 75.
No. Oh, we had
um there was like a weird mini batching
thing,
remember? So, this is where we said it
would be easier if
um if you did the thing where we like
crop it, do a big batch size, but then
you just picked a mini bin mini batch
size that works. also like cropping so
that the agents the M's just give you a
clean number
cuz remember I had to do
Yeah, we talked about the idea of just
picking the number of agents and then
picking the maps
accordingly. I I did not implement that.
Well, I will do something. I'll do the
same thing I did for now for before.
Okay. So, this is now training.
Yeah. And when I was trying to run this,
maybe maybe now it'll be fixed, but
before value loss started going crazy
mode.
I'm pushing you this path.
Yeah.
And then we will see whether value loss
is still
crazy. Very
weird.
Something is
Yeah, something is just like eating all
the
memory. There's this one command on
uh kill all literally doesn't do
anything. This freaking like ridiculous
thing that actually works.
every
time. One freaking stack overflow
post. So, something changed cuz this
only has 700k per.
this. I made the It was 64512, right?
Yeah, it was
512. Okay. And then we had N75, but I
get picking 64 doesn't really matter
either way. I did that to match um some
dimensions.
well. Now we're at 400k train.
Okay. With 50% copy overhead.
What is the copy overhead? I don't think
I ever knew. It's just taking the
observations and putting them on the
GPU.
I mean that task is mandatory, right?
You can't like not put it on GPU.
Technically in Python 314 if they nail
threading or if I write a C++
uh or a C-blaced my not C++ a C-based uh
thread back end for puffer ms we will be
able to um put stuff into torch
asynchronously on each worker so we
won't have to block on it.
So there is still more optimizing I can
do. You know the year is 2027. Puffer
trains at 20 million steps per
second. Well, I mean you started at 1
million and I think many are now in the
two to three range.
Mhm. We're making good progress.
The value
loss may or m may not be exploding.
Mine is going to like hundreds of
thousands.
Well, how immediately?
Within pretty quick range. Yeah, seems
fine.
Check our
Neptune. This is loading the uh the GPU
pretty well, I will say.
That doesn't actually mean you're using
it
effectively. There we
go. So, this is doing. So, it is okay.
It is learning again. So, I don't know
why mine was like going crazy, but maybe
because I just didn't have
the advantages change or whatever and
the puff
advantage. Uh, it's supposed to like
fail without that. So, I don't know what
you had.
I don't
know. But this seems close to what we
were getting yesterday. Yeah. I mean, it
was it capped at like point4, I think.
Okay. So, um let it What is the most
productive thing we can do with this? we
have it run a sweep or
um I think it would probably be worthy
of one checking to make sure my logging
is as correct as I believe it should be
for what we're trying to accomplish on
completion rate for being
score two looking at the data.
Okay, let's do that probably before
running the sweep. I know we talked
about yesterday sweeping and then
checking out data, but yeah, this is
lagging like local.
Uh the last one should be
by
200 time
match. Also why is it's 63
partner 64* 7 road.
So it's 60 because
there's up to 64 cars. So 64 minus one
is 63 partner
and then it's seven plus six on the
attributes for the road because there's
six one hot encoded
um categories of of the type of road
classifications.
But that's not what I mean that's not
what's in the observations here, right?
first.
See? Yeah. You're grabbing the road
points are totally messed up then if
there 13 attributes of them, right?
Wait, wait. Are you okay? Where is this
breakpoint? Is this breakpoint in torch
or is this breakpoint in
torch? Okay. Okay. So the observations
coming in should be in the shape of 200*
7 and then when they get passed into the
network they you get we I add in the the
one hot afterwards but even then that
number seems to be off somehow. Yeah.
None of these match
right? I guess this one this one
matches 1847.
Okay. So,
would 4136 be the number of aid? Wait,
this is the batch size.
Okay. So, if the 1847 is matching, that
makes more sense. So, it's 200 road
points and they each have seven
attributes.
Yes. And then I do the one hunt
afterwards when passing it to the
So what do these dimensions represent?
The first six should
The first one has two cars on top of
each other for the first point.
So the first point should have real goal
X and real goal Y. And these are all
normalized.
The first two observation calls are the
first two observations are the same
here.
How big is this
function? Possibly big.
I would argue something is funky. Then
it could be that it's like the same map
or something loaded that way, but it
would be weird.
It should be the second
map because each of those should be
their own independent
map. It would be a little odd if the
first one is copied to the same world
again.
Oh, we can't do this because you have
Syon.
We can't do it because you have Syon,
right?
Yeah. And damn
it. Uh, if you want to put it into
non-syon, we can try as
I don't think I've done anything to fix
your map loading shenanigans. I guess Do
you load them in Python anyways?
Does anything need to get What do you
actually need to pass to
these? You just pass observations,
actions, rewards,
terminals,
coefficients, offsets, and then yeah,
that's the weird thing I do is to get
the agent offsets. But you make these in
GPU drive and then you pass them to GPU
drive. Yeah.
So you don't use these for anything in
this Python.
No, but you use it in the Sython. So it
gets passed to
Syon because the Syon uses those offsets
to determine how to offset the
observations, rewards, and actions. Why
Why can't you just do this in the init?
Why can't this just be in the init?
Because numbum agents has to be set
ahead of time to the correct number.
Ah,
okay. Well, we can do that easy enough,
I
think. I don't know. It would be kind of
cool to get this into the new bindings
today. It would make debugging a hell of
a lot easier.
Do you use all this entity DT type stuff
that I think is an artifact at this
point?
thing? Total agent is basically making a
fake env to run a function to get the
right account.
with some small modifications then I
think we can make this work because
here this is the binding that I have for
uh the grid end and here I make I
generate all the maps in
C right so this gets called once at the
start and then I just
like where is it
levels. Yeah. So here like I make this
levels thing and I can actually return
it. You can return a pi
object. You could just return num maps
or whatever with this. Or you could just
init the levels either
way. This actually you you have to
create all the levels twice, don't you?
In the current approach, yes, because
one time you have to create the levels
to get the agent counts from them and
then the second one's the actual So
maybe this lets you just do it then
because here I make all the levels. I
don't return the count of them to be
fair, though that's easy enough to do.
And I keep the levels and see
the one Okay. I don't actually know if
that's an issue on this end, but it's
something we'll have to test out is if
we're going to break the memory limit.
The memory limit of what? Because it's
cal. There's a bunch of
cache
like that goes on when you initialize
the levels.
But that's like stack limit.
Yeah. But you can
cal you can put it on the heap.
I think we just I thought when we talked
about this we just determined that the
number may just end up being too big.
Well, if it doesn't fit on the heap,
then it doesn't fit in RAM,
right? I mean, how much RAM do we have?
What are you doing now if it's not in
RAM?
Well, it's only doing those 75 levels. I
thought I'm talking about like as you
get to like 10,000 levels. Oh, yeah. But
then like we all have the same bloody
problem in Syon or in or in this, right?
What does Syon let you do that you don't
know if you can do here?
Okay, if you just cal up each of the
states of a level. I mean, I think
you're going to have to what? Create a
new state object inside the inside of
the end.
Uh that's what we did for this for the
grid because we load and save a bunch of
levels very often is probably the way
you would want to do it because like
that's the same type of way I did it for
tower climb too is like I just generated
all the levels at once. The levels
aren't big. Wait, the levels aren't like
big, right? The issue is that when you
when you materialize them into the
format that's like efficient to compute
observations over, they get big, right?
Yes, that's correct. So we can just like
we can load them either fully expanded
or just like load the files and whatever
for now and then when you reset you can
rematerialize.
Okay, I'm I like that approach. Well, we
don't even we'll just do exactly what
you're doing now. That's just like we
have outs for when we want to scale
this.
Right.
Uh, the only thing is I guess if we want
to return both the levels and the um the
count, we might have
to think. So, do you no longer have to
return an array of offsets with this
approach? I don't think you do because I
think you can just get access to the
levels in in C, right?
cool. There's a little bit of PI API
shenanigans. So like ideally you want as
little code as possible in this binding
file and as much of it as possible in
theh it's pretty clean. This is the
whole binding file for grid and grid has
like you know procedure big set of
procedural levels and it swaps them in
dynamically on reset.
Yeah. I mean, I'm effectively going to
have to I'm going to copy that approach
for tower climb on how that binding will
work because they run the same way.
Yeah.
Um I'm trying to think what things
should be inside of theh file.
Well, everything that doesn't require
the Python API goes in
the binding should be as small as
possible.
Well, if we're saying we no longer need
the count
if you have access to levels, you don't
need the count, right? Because you just
like on init like in this init function
here, you would just go through and read
it, right?
But when you set up the Python side,
doesn't don't you have to tell the
agents for when
um
well, you need to know how many agents
are going to be made, I guess.
Yeah. When you when you super init the
actual GPU drive in Python. I mean, I've
been promising Aaron like um like a get
method as well. So, I could get you like
an extra get or something. You can
return whatever
we could do that from the from theh
files into the Python. Mhm.
I could just give you an extra binding
for a get method.
Yeah. I mean that would I think solve
that issue.
Unless a simpler solution.
It's not that hard.
I know. I just figured we had to do this
anyways. Like I'm sick of not being able
to to debug this complicated ass
environment.
What you thinking, Spencer?
Oh, I was um I thought we were going to
start on the news binding. Yeah, I like
I thought you were deciding a couple
things. I'm just sending a couple
messages on the uh the other thing we're
starting together. Uh all
right, let's
do binding shenanigans.
Yeah.
You have this working on a remote box
right now?
Um currently, yeah, let's just do it
there.
I was just running a
uh a train. I was just doing a train
just to make sure that everything was
still lining up. But on the box it looks
like Yeah. 420,000 470,000 or so. Want
to just do the
um should we just do the uh the
integration there so we can both edit
it? Yeah, that works. What box you want?
Uh
one box. Uno.
Sorry, I was ordering my uh my food.
There we are. T-Mox. Mine's not on T-Max
right now. Let me just
uh let me kill the run and then open up
a T-X. There is a T-ux here.
Oh, unless I
Yeah, it looks like it's an old one.
This is the right machine I'm on, right?
Yeah. I mean, if it says my name in
there somewhere in
there, like the if if the team's
attached is the end of Yeah. Pepper box
one.
The tank is
tank.
See what which one is your tank? Should
be puffer tank. Just the one without the
two.
Yeah, Spencer. Cool.
I think the two was I think Bet maybe
wanted to do something at one point.
Yep. All right.
So, have you done have you done any
binding ports yet? Yeah, this is
completely new to me. I haven't touched
any of the binding ports. So, I get to
show you how this works then.
Um, so what we do with this
And then there are a couple things
here. So we have a log
function. Anything that goes in log
should go here. Okay. Okay. So, all the
stats from uh GPU drive should go in
there. That's super easy.
What is Perf now? Is that supposed to be
a new
uh perf? That's a part of everything.
Yeah. So, I it would it's often times
going to be the same as score.
Okay. It's just a 01 normalized. It's
just 01 normalized is the main thing.
So, if you already have if the
completion rate it's the same. Yeah.
I'm still playing with stuff like
that. What we do is we take these stats.
Uh I think you also there are a couple
required
here. My visual does not have any visual
indicator. This is annoying.
You don't see your cursor? Uh, like when
I go to highlight stuff in visual mode,
there's no change. It's silly. Oh.
Score episode return episode length.
This that and float
return off-road collision and
okay cool
now now we have all that done
uh now for a net we need to know what
args so those are just whatever you have
in GPU drivep Pi that is currently being
put into
here. You have this signature right now.
Okay. So we have it looks like human
agent index.
You unpack you have a reward. You have
this and then the offsets we're handling
separately.
Okay. And then you
have there an init function
in the Python or just in general in theh
in theh. Yeah, there's an init. It's
just it should just be an init by
itself.
It takes the end, right? Yeah. Yeah. And
then what's this handle
Um, so this state is going to be the
levels thing that we're going to make.
We're actually probably going to be able
to keep this similar and like whatever
levels is called or whatever, however we
do
this. Like I think we just we'll give it
we just give all the M's the pointer to
all the levels and you just pick
whichever one and then it's shared
memory anyways.
Okay. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. And now the only other thing
is the level initialization. So this
gets called once for all ends. This gets
called at the start. And this just lets
you call whatever C you
Yes.
So like this
here, this is what you wanted to do for
a net pretty much.
You have this function here that takes
in. You need rewards for get total agent
count.
No,
you need just num m, right?
You should just need which is num maps.
Why did I
It should be numb maps, not num m,
shouldn't it? Or dumb mum maps. I don't
I think I assumed that when I was doing
my like Python to Sython stuff, I was
just keeping everything the
same in order to initialize the
environment. Okay, but you really should
only need
numm,
which is just a variable name for just
could be num maps.
Okay. So then can you fill in um what
grid even knows
can you fill in logic here to like load
the num num m's maps or
whatever. If I just exit I will uh I'll
exit out so I don't I'm not on
there. I'm I'm out of it. So, make sure
you over right now.
Okay. So, you can now see my stuff.
Uh, yeah. Okay.
Okay. And so, what do you want me to do?
You want me to set up the function like
how I did in Syon, but here?
Yeah. Yeah, just calling the C. So all
you have to do is load num maps
levels and you're going to be able to
return a pointer of this to Python which
will then be you'll be able to use in
the C
Okay, so here's something I did that I
don't know
how if this is going to be the best way
to go about it. I made a bunch of GPU
drive
instances temporarily. Are we still
going to go with that as the approach?
because I mean this is effectively the
function that I'm going to be
and then we're no longer caring about
offsets.
Um, well, I mean, you don't need to
return offsets if you just have the
levels. Okay. So, if you just want the
the the level to be
loaded, this is the part where I'm a
little confused on how we're going to be
implementing this as part of the now the
new binding.
What are we actually storing now?
So, uh, you just store there's one
calic, right, for the
levels. Like this one calic up here for
levels. It's not a state. It's whatever
the level object is.
Okay. So, I don't have a level object.
Okay. You have you just have M's or
whatever though, right? You have like
temp M's. I just have like I just have
the whole n and then like entities.
Okay. So then it would just be num m*
size of m or whatever and you'll pass a
pointer to that whole array.
ends where this would be like the actual
strct.
on. I think I only would need to do load
map binary at the moment. If you're
saying that we're no longer using, if we
no longer are taking this count object
back into Python,
we don't need what? I'm saying active
agents can just be put
into like you don't I don't think you
have to call all of the things inside of
my init.
No, I we just need to know either you
make the maps or you just compute the
number or what this is just this
function. All this function does is it
lets you return something to Python. It
lets you compute some stuff and return
stuff to Python. If you want that to be
a pointer to all the M's, like all the
levels, you can do it that way, right?
Like because you don't you don't load
the M's. Do you load all the M's inside
of each each C environment or C
instance?
I am loading. You do it once in the
Sython layer, right?
Once in the Syon layer, I knit them all.
That would be this
Okay. But in this case, I'm writing in
what? Python here.
At least what I see on my screen. Yeah,
you're rewriting in C.
Oh, this whole thing's supposed to be in
C. You not see the notate. That's the
Python C API. PI object star start star
start star pointer. It's like it's the C
API. Okay, hold on.
Let's let us correct the situation.
Okay. So if I'm just basically
recreating the init then I just need the
map
So would I just be initializing this
like I normally would in the Sython
this? So this is the part where I just
don't really understand how I'm supposed
to be doing the lighting because I would
generally pop in my offsets here and
just initialize the
how I don't know why it keeps spamming
me with like this
giant block of
you seeing the dots on the right block.
It's just giant giant
dots.
Um what? So, like you want are you used
to having like an F string to load maps
or
something? Is that the thing that you're
I don't know what we're trying to
accomplish right now in this particular
section like I'm trying to load the map
the thing that you have in Syon right
now but I got distracted with some
messages on the side again here
configur you have some like load map
thing right here right
load so you have this thing right here
that does like this loading in temp and
then you do it again somewhere, right?
No. Where's the map? Where do the maps
get loaded here?
I just call in it again in the uh
where does it pick the map? I passed in
the map file to the end again. I just
call it
afterwards. You can do that as well.
Like if you want to like load them
twice, you can also do that. It's up to
you if you want to do it like the way it
would have to be with tower climbing the
grid or you just want to do it this. I
mean, either way, you're going to have
to load them to check how many agents
there are,
right? If you just want to load them
like to check if you just want to like
load them to check how many agents there
are for now and just return the number
of agents, that's fine, too.
And this can all just be done in this
area of C. So I can set up like an N but
then just basically do the exact same
thing I did. You can write arbitrary C.
Oh
yes, you have you can write arbitrary C
and then within the confines of what is
easy to do with the Python C API, we can
pass arbitrary data back to Python.
Because the whole point of me doing
the first round of setting up the M's
was to set up offsets. When you say set
up offsets, it's it's to figure out the
total number of agents, isn't it? It's
to figure out the total number of agents
and also when you're passing
in to a specific
Oh, yeah. Yeah, I remember that thing.
Yeah. Okay. The variable number of
agents that you have in that map and
where to tell your observations to
start. Okay. Then in that case, then
just return the whole offsets thing.
Sure.
Okay.
Yeah, I see what you Okay, I I
understand now why that is there. Um
that's why I was like, am I just
replicating my Sython? Yeah, in that
case then you are. Yeah, that case you
are. Then the only thing I have to
figure out for you is how to
um you probably are going to have to
like make a pile list and do like pile
ad or some [ __ ] but other than
that, it'll be fine.
Okay. All right.
Yep. Okay. So now I have my agent
offsets. I have the total
count inside of agent
offsets. And then now I can set up
the actual end with its
offsets. Uh hang on. So you have first
of all you're writing Python inside of C
here, right?
All right. Fair enough.
Let me go find you the PI
Okie dokie. Okay. So, you will have to
do this shenanigans, but it's not that
bad.
I don't know why it is that I see like
four lines of your screen flying around
on my screen. I My bad. I clicked it a
few times.
I was trying to see what you were doing
because it like it keeps shrinking my
view to like four lines of your
So because now when I did this in the
Sython, what I did was I
had use these temp environments to set
up my
this. I presume I have to free these as
well.
Well, you just made one calic. So,
well, no, because whenever I do
something on the inside with the calling
those functions, I'm I'm also doing
other things.
There's more cal in the in the C then.
Yes.
So, kind of gross. We should find a
cleaner way of doing all this. But I at
least want to get this thing into the
freaking end binding, the new end
binding, so we can stop dealing with
Syon hell.
Going to be very nice for you to be able
to like set break points through Python.
I would
think also this is useful so that with
the new environment we were going to be
doing um we can just do it this way from
the start, right?
Yeah. Especially if we're adding on to
it and you know adding bigger maps and
things like
that. I say it is a really odd feeling
to be like converting
um like Python into C as I'm like
reading Python.
You've been spending too much time
looking at Python.
Then not a fun language. This is just a
matter of having to translate over as
I'm reading. It's like sheet reading new
piano.
Look, I personally would be very, very
happy to be spending more time writing C
environments instead of all the stuff
I'm dealing with lately. Okay,
so I don't want to free agent offsets,
but I want to take out the temp
environments because I don't need that
variable anymore. Oh man, this is so
gross. I basically do this three times
of looping this over, but this should be
the last time. Why do you have to do
what's the next one for
the actual initialization of the maps? I
thought you were just figuring out the
numbers.
I thought you were just
round one is
getting what's commenting in this
hashtag
double slash. You've been writing C for
a while. Like what? Also C doesn't have
F strings.
All right. So, like these are like the
whole point of the top one is to get the
agent count. Uhhuh.
And the offsets. Isn't that all you
need? You're setting up the whole
environment, right? So, well, you can I
have to free all the excess things. I'm
just confused because the way you have
it in the Sython at the moment, like
yes, this is a way that we can do it
that would probably be better than what
you have in the Syon, but like
why? I mean, you could just make the
bloody M's right here and be done or no?
And then I guess here. How do I
know which end is which OBS are going to
which end? Okay. At what point? So, what
if you just do this? You return the I
guess you have to return the offsets and
the end, which is a little bit awkward,
but we can do it.
Um, and then you just have to like it's
literally just setting pointers for the
observations and rewards and stuff,
right?
Yeah. When you're just setting
observations to observations and you
just you're giving it the first point in
where in that pointer you're going to.
But yeah, so you can just make the M's
here. Hang on. So like if we make the
M's here. Okay, here. Hang on. We make
the M's here.
We This doesn't show highlights at all,
but we make the M's here. We return
these offsets. And we also return the
M's, which are no longer
temp. Okay. And then in here, we get the
levels or we get the we already have the
M's.
Mhm.
Well, it's a little awkward because it's
expecting new M's.
Yeah. Fine. We'll just
do then. All we have to do is return the
offsets, right? And we make the new M.
All we have to do in this top one is
return the offsets like in in Syon. And
you don't need this third loop. You just
you you did the you made the things, you
did the free,
and now I just have to show you how to
return some offsets.
Right.
Yes. We just have to return the agent
offsets. Okay. Let me help with that
integer
array. Let me see. I p I
And while you're doing that, I'm gonna
have to remember how to do
It's something like this. Probably
missing a cast. Get rid of this grid
whatever [ __ ]
Yeah.
Click the f string as well. Uh you can
technically you already have Ray
imported here. So you can use text
format, right?
Ray's text format if you just want to do
something quick.
I don't think I know what you mean by
that. I mean, you don't know Ray's text
format. Ray has a thing that essentially
gives you an fstringish.
Are you just talking about the the the
string copy function? No, Rayb has a
function called text format.
No, unfamiliar with that. It's really
nice. I mean, you can also just like
print like whatever it, but like here
text format
const star text format of constar char
star text and then stuff you want to
format it
with. Yeah, whatever. Do just do just do
it however you want to do it.
This a real
thing?
Wait, I must have like put breakout as
these don't look like breakout
According to this, we have some nice
very very fast maze learning
now. Like 10x faster than before
10 times. Yeah.
Than the previous sweep at
least. Now we're getting almost the
result that we got before, but we're
getting it in a minute and a half.
instead of in 10 minutes.
So, you have to leave in 10 minutes. No,
we're getting the result that we used to
take 10 minutes. I got until 6 p.m.
Fair
enough. I don't know if this is valid C.
I think it is. But
well, isn't it so nice that we're going
to actually get real C compile errors
now instead of whatever Sython does?
Cuz I swear to God, doesn't this just
print it? Like this is not I don't think
this actually sets the value of it to it
does, but I I don't think it's map file.
There's a comma or something missing.
I don't think is that the format I
percent I thought it was percent. I
don't freaking remember.
I just want to run it and see what
happens.
All right. So, how do I run this? So,
well, we're going to have to change the
um the binding file, right? I guess we
can compile it for now. But so, all you
have to do to compile this is uh you go
to the setup.py
Okay.
You move the binding from Syon to
Okay. You move the binding from Syon to pure C extensions.
pure C extensions.
Oh, this drill again. Okay. Mhm.
Do you have to do this every time? What?
the reload the regular extensions and
then the C extensions after the torch
extensions again afterwards. Uh the
torch extensions aren't going to need to
be recompiled.
I'm looking for
but yes, when I'm actually editing the
torch extensions, I do have to do this a
bunch and it's a pain in the
ass. You also I meant that you had to
like move it from side GPU drive to the
Purd extensions
version. Okay. So, it's in there. I just
saw it. It's somewhere in here. Yeah,
you just passed it. Up, up, up, up.
Going there.
Oh, you're saying take this out. Yep.
And that's going to go into pure C
extensions.
Okay. Okay. I'm just going to put it in
the front.
Okay. And don't I have to also uncomment
the thing to recompile this correctly?
Yes. Uh unless it's already set up
correctly. Yeah. So that move So go from
torch extensions to like uh C
extensions up. You passed it. It's in
the middle of your
screen. Okay. Down a little bit. Am I
just blind?
Yes. Yes. Right there. Oh, there we go.
The C extensions
and then comment the command class.
Forgot to comment the command class.
GG, dude. Where's that?
I'm doing this. No, it's right there. I
was gonna press the comment button. You
You took too long to press the comment
button.
Also, I'm going to give you a a really
nice thing that you should do. Increase
the key repeat speed on your system. You
will thank me later.
Okay, that's pissed off.
Yeah, because it's including the grid
file.
Oh, I should probably include my file.
And then N hash define uh or pound
define N GPU drive, whatever your
that
like that. Literally the line below that
you're looking at.
Oh, okay. Got you.
You've been getting asleep, man.
Oh, man. This is just like live
education. All right. Okay.
Come on, Jess. Give him a break. I was
just like this is how I this is how I
act when I've been like a couple days on
like five hours of sleep. Yeah, for a
long time. But like
all right, it took me time to learn and
binding. H it's pissed
off. You don't have terminals in here.
All
right. Did B just come in here? You just
came in here to give me [ __ ] for giving
you [ __ ] That's funny.
All right. Finding.h.
Yeah. So GPU drive doesn't have a
variable named
terminals. What we're going to do, I
think I called it dun.
Okay, now we got to update the logs. I
guess we got to update the log
structure. So, here's the cool
thing. Um, is this where you press
delete? Yeah, this is literally where
you just get to go like this. Go up
to Forget. Do you still need log buffer?
You don't even need log buffer, do
log. Look at all that code that's gone.
Okay, nice. Just dropped like 20 lines.
You still need ad log, but it should uh
it should add basically it should add to
them.
Was is it like N or is it
GPU five star N? Should be star end.
Yeah. Okay. So, we do
Uh, this is actually going to be you.
So, you need to add you need to add the
stats of the agent that is finished to
to this. So, I don't know if this takes
agent. This probably takes like
Oh, it would take an index. It's
probably like this or
something like
like it's probably like some [ __ ] like
this.
whatever. It's like something like
this. I can show you the example on my
screen in a
second. Okay,
So in this case, since we're doing the
multiple agents within it, would this ad
log be assumingly only taking being
called for that specific agent?
However you want to do it. So like does
are you logging all the agents right at
the end of the episode now?
Right now I am logging all of them at
the end of at the end of the episode.
Correct. Okay. And I just I loop through
all of the active agents.
See, so then this block of code I pass
it.
This I Guess you are
storing you're storing a bunch of
logs anyways in here. You have like the
separate logs thing.
Yeah, I mean you have the off-road rates
get set earlier but you don't call ad
log until the end. Okay, so this is
going to be
And then do you also have to do like all
the episode return and episode length
here as well?
Yeah. So like what's the score variable?
Score variable's completion rate.
Is it in logs or like where do we get it
from?
It's in the end.
M completion rates or something.
You can see what I'm doing here, right?
I'm filling it into this one log and I'm
aggregating. Can you fill the rest of
this out real
quick? Like do you understand what this
is trying to do?
Okay. So there's one log object. There
is one log object and it's cumulative.
So every time like an agent needs to
log, it adds its stats into that and it
increments the n variable by one. And
then uh our login code in the M binding
will take the mean for you and also
aggregate across like multiple C
instances.
But in this case we aren't we calling
add log.
Okay. We're only calling it one time. So
if
then we're moving it in here and we're
looping through all of them. Yeah. So if
you can just add those stats in then
this will work and the uh logging stuff
will be pretty well ported. Obviously
you just got to change a couple other
small calls. There's no more buffer
object or anything like that. I don't
know what you mean by other stats
because the other stats are already
dumped in here. Uh it doesn't have
length, return, or perf all that. I
mean, wouldn't those just be from like
you see this is m.log, right? Not logs
or log buffer. There's one
log. Yeah, it's just like it's whatever
the existing variable is that you use
for this. I just I haven't looked at it
in a while, so I don't know what
everything is named. and like where it's
stored. Anyways, if you take a look at
that for a few, I'm going to just go use
the restroom real quick. I'll be back in
a couple. Okay. All right.
I'm trying to figure out what is the
part that is confusing here. Is it like
not understanding how the Python API
stuff works in or like I think it's I'm
trying to understand is where does like
how is this different than the original
log system? So in the original log
system there was this big buffer that
you had to keep filling up and you had
to have all the m share this buffer and
then we had a function that would take
the mean over that.
Right? So now there's just one log. you
add stuff into it and with just an extra
n variable and you just everything gets
divided by that n automatically for you.
So you don't have to have this extra
like log buffer object anymore. Um you
just have the one log variable and then
aside from that the only difference
instead of you calling like instead of
like you having to call like this
aggregate and clear or whatever this
just gets done for you through the
ending stuff
and that affect how I'm setting the logs
though.
Uh you're no longer interacting with a
log buffer and you are adding adding to
the log instead of like setting the log,
right? Because the log buffer is each
element is the log of one agent. And now
this log is every time you have an agent
ready to log it stuff, you add the
values of that log to the current values
of the log and you increment n by one.
Okay. For
example, in my step function, Mhm.
I'm setting logs of my collision rates
and my off-road rates to occur and my
episode returns and my rewards are all
being adjusted at various moments,
right? Oh, okay. So, by the time you're
done with this is like do you have all
the values that you need in in those
logs? They're already in there. Well,
like episode return is cumulative and
stuff, right? Like Yeah, I see. Right.
The line below. Okay. So, let's go back
up to Hang on. So, if we go back to a
[ __ ]
this is like the uh what's like the Oh,
let me help you. Two people typing on a
keyboard meme. Yeah,
two people. When you're telling me to
like add the stats back in, that's why
I'm confused because the stats are
already in there. Okay. So, here, well,
the stats aren't in this log variable,
right? So, then here, this is literally
all it is. It's just you don't need
this. Well,
you this DNF rate isn't in there, right?
This is like calc separately.
That's a new one. That's calc
separately. So, are you saying that like
this new log is just going to be the
same thing as pulling into end
logs and just copying it from that
attribute?
Yeah. So, this should just be logs I
episode and just do the exact same
thing. You're just copying it.
Yeah. Logs. What is it? Score. Perf. Uh
what's the score variable?
Okay. Like that's what I I didn't know
what you were calling it and stuff. So
that's that's what I understand. It's
like what's the point of copying it here
if score is being set above.
Oh. Okay. So this was but this is Oh,
right, right, right. I see. Because it's
just reach score. So this is done then.
So all literally all it is is this. Hold
up. So episode length is going to be
different.
Um because I that's what I was trying to
understand. So if episode length just
the OG episode length let me get rid of
something real quick because well I mean
you could define it you could define it
any one of like many ways you want. You
could also define it as like you know it
could be like uh the average amount of
steps the agent is alive. You could
define it many ways because right now
that number is just going to be
effectively 91. Yeah,
that's fine. Okay. Because I wasn't
certain if you wanted this to just be a
running tick that goes on infinitely.
No, it should right now reset and step.
Yeah. So, it's just going to be 91.
Okay. Hold up. And let me just but you
can see like they're just like I have
everything do length return score perf
and n because those are variables that
you expect to have. Some m are going to
have finite horizon like constant
horizon. That's fine.
Okay. Then this should be everything.
All right. Cool. So we can compile it
because you already have you log in
there. You okay? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
changed and binding.h no member
log we need it needs a
log. So instead of having a log buffer,
it will have
log
log. And I believe it is a log star, not
a log. Hang on one
second because my log star logs is the
one that's going to be doing it per
agent. And then the big buffer log is
going to be this one, right? This log.
Yes.
Okay. Log dot. Yes. So I have my
variable logs that I'm have in the end
and then I'm just copying those over to
this log which is just meant to be a
simpler one because of the whole getting
rid of Syon. Well, the only reason you
have the multiple logs in the first
place is because of um because multi-
aent. Yes. Because it's multi- aent,
right? Otherwise you would just like,
you know, whenever the agent is done.
Otherwise, I would just have like random
variables in there as stats. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly.
Okay. Is it not called GPU
drive or is this need um a
prototype? I guess technically we could
pass like other stuff to this, but I
think I just usually move these
up here.
Maybe not that
Incomplete type GPU drive is weird. Oh,
wait. There's a semicolon missing.
this? Why does it say incomplete type? I
can just move this below technically,
right?
I can totally just move this
down attribute perf. So we have to
add this needs to have uh what is
Okay. So, now we're just uh we're into
the bindings
definition it's why is it num m's plus
one for the offsets Spencer.
I was on mute. Uh, the last one's the
total coin. The last one is the total.
Mhm. Oh, okay. So, I have to do plus
one and then you have to do pilot set
item.
Okay. So now we're just on to like this
temp and not existing, right?
Yeah, these are all missing. Yeah, these
are all just missing semicolons.
semicolon before four. Oh, set your set
items. Do those have to have semicolons,
too? I guess all of this does. I'm C.
It is C.
Okay. Uh, you passed it. It's in the
middle of pilot set items. Pilot set
items.
that one.
Oh,
and then that's the wrong one.
There's another. Is there another one?
No, I think that's it. All right, let's
see what happens.
No, still pissed.
I don't know why it says uh it can't
find temp
Okay.
Pointer
pointer versus dot declaration. Yeah,
it's entities. This
is
agents. Entities has no member num
agents.
Is this not just temp MUM
agents? What is
Um, no. It's it's it's an autocomplete
issue. It's tempm's numbum
entities. And that may end up having to
be uh, wait, hold up, hold up, hold up.
Your total count
What's this X? Is this I? No, that would
be J. That's J.
Hold up. Your total count. I'm
suspicious
on Yeah. Hold up. Your total count's
wrong. Oh, good. I got it to compile
now. Fix fix
Okay, that should be good.
Good timing.
Air. Why is it mad? Hold up.
incompatible
type in the pilot set item.
21 incompatible types from type int on
total count. That should be like a pi in
or some dumb thing.
end? Oh, why do you have to use pilot
set item? Why do you why are you
including total counts at all? Because
aren't you only getting the agent
offsets? Yeah, that's what I was
long. So it's not pylon from void
pointer.
Hang
on. Where are we
looking? Yes, this is separate. So the
agent offsets right here.
It's pissed off about set item.
mad? Where is
error? Unknown
type by long.
So now you see why I was trying to
minimize the uh user exposure to this
like kind of ass API.
Yeah.
The less Python API you have to touch
the better.
Pi
object. This is a pi
Obviously we have to
uh edit the um Python code a little bit
to like use the new binding,
He's saying we should compile and
recompile with force.
That was like 30 minutes ago. Oh, so I
don't know at what point that was
relevant. Oops, my bad. That missed it.
No, it was just a chat in the general
chat message. So, it wasn't like on
called. Now we do total agents yada
yada. We have to
do total agents or no agent
offsets. That's
So this is where you get the binding
from the my shared function. So it's
binding.shared and then what was it? Num
ms.
Yeah, I think we did num ms equals num
ms. Looks like
this. Okay. Okay. And then we get uh
total
agents
offsets minus one should be the last
one. Yeah.
Then now you can get rid of all that.
So now we have
super. Now we have to we can't use this
vein it just the way that it's used here
because you have like fancy stuff.
selfobservations of what is it? Agent
like this probably actions reward. I I
think I to I plus one seems about right.
It's probably just this, right? Yeah.
Like
uh
equals next.
And then what else did we pass? Human
agent index.
Yeah, human agent index, reward,
vehicle,
off-road,
and map name. You got to toss in map
name. Also
needs
seed. Uh what params did we
define binding?
Just just those three you're talking
about
um human
agent reward vehicle reward off-road and
map name but we have to find map name
now
again do we not or is it just get passed
in from you just need the
index All right.
Just pass with the index.
Is it because now you're going to pass
the way that this thing is supposed to
work, right? So, we do this invite is
appendid and then we just do self
CMS and then this this new thing is
almost identical. This is like
binding.ve
reset
selfcms also it needs seed as
well.
Um and then this is like
binding.step. This is
binding dot
backlog. And that's it. I guess well
I actually don't know what the heck is
with
the that I think I probably haven't done
that in a while. It's probably binding
back
render. Try
Syon and we need these variables need to
be defined
though we already have right
yeah now you have N by Okay. And now you
can make the
uh you can do this,
right? You can make your maps from this
in. You don't have map name in Maya
init. You have the M ID. Just need this,
right?
Well, from that all we got was the total
counts for the offsets.
We didn't actually initialize any any
but this is literally just
Yeah. And we don't need state. We're not
doing
this. So yeah, you literally just have
to make your or you just have to call
init on this. So what what is it? It's
it's in it. It should just be a nit. And
you never call a nit up here, right?
Intentionally, but you need to call a
nit after you set the file. know. Yeah.
The map file.
So, sprint
f. Does it do you set it like end map
name or something or do you put it in
init or what?
It's inside of the init parameters.
There's a map file um like map f like
this.
It's sorry it's called map name. It's
called map
name. No, no, no. It's not like init.
It's it's it's it's as part of the uh
oh like Python initiation.
So end map name.
be like this. And map name equals the
map should be the map file. Yeah. Except
this is does map name. Is this like a
void? Does this have its own buffer? Do
I have to malic this? What do we do?
Before I didn't I I just had it I think
on the stack.
Yes, cuz this is just Yeah, this is just
a All right. Yeah. Okay. I'm being dumb.
Yeah, this should work. Cool. So, isn't
this everything or am I missing
something?
Um, the weird part for me is I
guess you no longer need to pass map
name inside of the Python. Now, I just
passed the ID instead of having to deal
with unpacking a
string. I passed the ID in, right, which
I'm using to determine what map to load.
And is and that ID is being incremented
from one to number of MS.
Yeah. See? Okay. That flies.
Same thing, right?
Yes, that would be the same thing. And
then you get these ids which is these
are really pointers and you vectorize
one of these pointers. So what this env
does this returns you a pointer to the C
object.
Okay. And then vector takes a bunch of
these pointers. Believe this is star.
uh yeah star. So it just takes all the
envids that you've made and then it
turns you it gives you essentially a
double
pointer and then that is what mb binding
expects. So like all these functions you
see they just take this pointer.
So, this is you telling the
C what object it
cool. And then the VEX step just knows
to step each one of those. Yep. because
you gave it you specifically have given
it a double pointer to your
M's and it knows how many there are from
the initialize.
Okay. Yeah.
Too many arguments to init. So init
file, right? This was Yeah, I I just
misunderstood the first time. No, it's
fine.
Okay. Uh was it clean
pepperm
train
fault? Very scary. Seg
Um, we have to update container to get
GDB, dude. G [ __ ] G.
Seriously, you see I have not been in
Python land because obviously I would
have used a debugger.
Well, this debugger is not happy with
us.
The one thing I haven't figured out how
to do is um compile this in a way that
the address sanitizer plays nicely with
um uh with like torch and stuff. It
should be possible technically, but that
I have not figured out how to do yet.
How to just enable the address sanitizer
on these
files. That's still annoying.
Um, I'm trying to think what's the
easiest way to figure this stupid thing
out. Like I'm sure we just like init
like are indexing something that doesn't
make sense, right? I would tend to
believe that's the only way that you
would get a psych at this point.
I don't know. Do we see anything obvious
here?
In the beginning, I do size of GPU
drive. Does it know what GPU drive is?
Yeah, it's macro right here. Okay. But
it's imported actually, right? It's
included right here. You have access to
everything in GPU drive.
Um, let's see if we get back. Let's see
if we get back the offsets into Python
or if we even get there. Are
are we calicking the M's at all?
Oh, we are
cuz freed the temporary M.
Yeah, get done for you. Okay.
Okay. Okay. So, whatever it probably is
returning this as a pointer is the
thing. Are you looking up how to
dreference the pointer from the Python
API? It's just the signature of uh the
shared function.
mildly
annoying. I kind of forgot about that. I
mean, I can fix it. I'm just trying to
think what the easiest thing to do
easily that we're going to have to
branch for this though.
But I mean I will fix it pretty directly
after
that. Hang on. Static pi object
star. This returns a pi
dict.
Ah, this
is totally wrong.
go. It was uh much simpler than I
expected. It was just a
bad turn
value. Well, I say having not fixed it
all. I don't have any break points in
here now though. I forgot. I think they
took the breakout point out by
mistake. So it doesn't it doesn't get to
total agents
or to at least to here.
Huh.
Is it still thinking that it's just
giving like a giant memory address? It's
seging when you attempt to access it. So
I don't actually know if you need this
this deck
rep without
it. What was the reason why you did
that? Why I did what? You set up the
deck ref.
Uh so Python has a Python has reference
counting. So their C API tries to like
count how many references there are to a
thing and when there are none left it
destroys the object. It's like garbage
collection,
right? It's really
annoying. Did I get out of the team up
somehow?
Yes.
I'm in here, right?
Oh, I got booted
out. It says there's no sessions.
We did something screwy in here
basically. Is there some way to run
through this file?
Like is there a way to set point? We
should be able to just do that. Yeah,
actually I don't know why it's I should
have thought of that. Ul ocean GPU
drivebinding
C line seven.
Okay, cool. So now we actually have
break points in C run from Python.
Pretty cool.
Yeah, this is sick. So we have 64 M. We
can see that gets passed correctly,
right? Yep. M M get our agent
offsets. We get
our map file here which has garbage in
it.
Do you think it's being read improperly?
Like the map file is not like a real map
file name. Now it is now that we printed
to
it. You see? Mhm. This is null
terminated.
It just has whatever other.
agents zero. Well, that's an issue.
Yeah.
Where's total count come
from? Oh, wait. It gets No, cuz see it's
correct. It's supposed to be zero.
Total count should not exist. Should
still be zero. It hasn't been adjusted
at all.
Well, this is temp m zero. And isn't
that cool? It prints this out like a
strruct.
It actually prints nested strruct. I
didn't even know it did that.
Well, it looks like active agent count
exists.
Num cars, numbum objects. Total agents
though. Active agent count is two,
out. It should be two. Yeah, there it
is.
And that's because active agent count
was three.
All these freezer like this is what you
do, right?
That's what I did in the siphon.
It wouldn't surprise me if one of those
freeze is the reason why this is pissed
off though. Yeah. So, let's try that
next. We are getting correct. Wait, are
we doing Wait, is that temp of I of J or
temp of J of I?
Uh, I don't know. Temp I.
We want to see if it works without it.
Yeah. Wait, you commented out the
route? Ah, wait. We have to increment
the ref. No.
then. Is it being described as a pi deck
right now?
Oh, it's a pi. Uh, it's a pi list what
we are
What is the What is the purpose of
having total count in the pilot set
item? Well, you wanted total count,
didn't you, for something? Well, if if
agent offsets has already inside of it
the last value as total count, you don't
need to return total count
anymore because you're just dre you're
just dreerencing the last point of the
array of offsets to get the
count. Uh, okay.
And it does seem like it is rebuilding
this thing correctly as well. Right.
I'm not seeing any errors. It Well, it's
not like sometimes it
Okay. Still
pissed. Your team, you ran out again.
Oops. And now it's actually going to
have to
faults. This is why I try not to do too
much in this this section, by the way,
cuz like it gets really obnoxious very
quickly.
Okay. So, what is the reason why you
need to set this pylong and total count
where oh, so I'm adding I'm just I'm
adding stuff into a Python list for you
because we're returning a Python list.
Okay.
So, this is a Python. So, that's what
set item does. So, set item takes like
the thing you're sending it to, the
index of it, and then Oh, this is the
issue right here. Um, because you're
setting the index as
Yeah. And I I was set it to the wrong
thing. It needs to be set to
Oh, nice. For honor and country. Wait,
but the last one's null. Well, we we
added an extra one for total agents, and
you told me we didn't need it.
So, do we want it or not? Oh, okay. I
just I think I misunderstood how that
the Python how the API works. Yes, we
still need it because we need to set up
the numbum agents for the
um what's it
called? Don't you need numbum agents
whenever you initialize the puffer
like the Python the the super innit from
Python? Yeah.
Okay. So now the total count should be
like 582
57 there are 64 m. Oh okay.
Aha. That sounded about right.
requires five arguments.
Right.
I don't know.
We could just chill here instead. That'd
be
cool. We might have to go make sure it's
actually
like doing stuff
though. Yeah. And to be fair, this is
one of the more complicated uses. This
and grid is the only thing that has like
a shared at the moment.
nurmoal. All right. So, we just do um be
backend serial.
though. We could have caught these
things with checks if I were not being
lazy. Okay. So, because this is not an
int or wait, no, is this an int?
Oh, this is an int.
I think invite is an
int. a human agent
index. I mean, we can always double
check by just printing it out.
But I mean, I guess we just go here
then, right? We go uh to here and make
sure stuff's getting initialized
correctly. Yeah, because it for sure
would instantly seg if the map is not
being read in.
So, we do
OBS actions, rewards, terminals,
truncations,
seed. And then we have these
me. It's breaking before on it and
venet unless I just unless I I loaded
the library wrong. Let me see.
Oh, it's binding
C. I loaded the binding
zero. That's
right. Zero reward off-road collision
doesn't seem
right. No, it should probably pull it in
from the config now.
Oh, wait. No, I just printed the wrong
one.
Right. I mean, they'll both be 75 either
way.
Did you just type it wrong or Yeah,
I typed the one that hadn't been set
yet. See? So, like after it sets. Okay,
then that's fine. If I do zero,
the first one should be okay. Okay,
let's see if that gets the map.
Resources GP drive binaries.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that that is how we
do. I'm trying to think if there's a
relative path
issue if there would be anything with
that.
see how we do it in uh
I don't think there is
in Syon it accepted resources but I
don't know about the
this oh maybe there
is but I did it with neural mammone and
I didn't have any issues
Wait, wait. Do Do the binaries even
exist in your version? Did we confirm
that?
good data.
I don't see anything that would be
off like it it's clearly running the set
active agent count. It's
running your sets.
Is there any is it? So, yeah, it's got
to be loading the map correctly then. If
it's if it's doing that, it has to be
loading the map. It would have no way of
loading the map um
correctly. If it those numbers if those
numbers were not the numbers they
currently are, or literally any number,
it would have broken them before then.
Here's M by D1.
It's different
data. Active agent count three. So the
offset is still
correct. Let's uh let's see if we can
actually like compile and run the C
Oh yeah, I just always use GCC, but I
don't know if it makes any
difference. I think that was in the C
file.
So something happened because this is
like a tenth the speed it used to be.
Did you do compile local versus compile
fast? No.
Okay, that matches. So, it still works
here. Um, let's see. I
guess do we get through in it now? It's
loading the map.
It's getting
through set active agents.
getting through. What else would be
breaking inside there?
Ah, so one of these M's it fails on one
of these vectorized calls.
Is it the last one? Is it going too far
because there should only Well, these
are per worker. This is one per worker.
No, I've only done eight. We have like
16 workers or whatever, right?
It's weird that it only eventually like
it it doesn't always fail on this,
right? I mean, I can try to run with a
dress sanitizer
symbols. This thing is the thing that
always messes us up like trying to debug
this way. I never know how you get these
symbols.
obnoxious. I don't know how we
uh how we're supposed to do this.
I'm going have to put more time into
figuring out this debugging stack
because it's it's pretty darn
nice. Um, except in this exact
instance where it's like some like
random seg that happens
again? Sorry, I had to take a quick
phone call.
Mhm. In a knit here.
Are you going over the Syon now to try
and find like a difference?
Yeah, this is only
taking map name,
reward. We got all these things. We
don't have log buffer anymore.
nine. Well, this is this would be index
eight or map
eight. The map start from zero, right?
The maps start from zero,
correct? Let me verify that real quick,
but I'm pretty sure that's true.
I mean, it fails on it loads the maps
correctly eight times and then the ninth
time it tries to load the maps, it
fails. That's kind of
weird. That's extremely odd.
MS. I can't think of what would be
different. Like it's even on serial,
right? It loads them eight times or
whatever and then it fails on the ninth
time. Okay. Sorry, I was dealing with
like a minor
crisis. Um, okay. Okay. So, it's failing
on the eighth one every single time.
Is it a weird vectorization
multi-processing thing? I tried it with
serial.
Why would it break on the eighth?
Maybe if we're lucky, we might get a
sane back trace from it.
Okay, that looks like it is something to
do with the map, right? Pi unic code
from format.
Where are you looking at when you're
looking? Oh, pi unicord from format V.
But wait, this is inside of
of
I don't even know if this is a correct
stack trace though because this is like
inside of random numpy stuff,
right? I feel like if it's inside of
numpy that then
I I I find it would be very odd if it's
inside of the map
Do we know how far it gets in the ninth
one?
Uh, no. Or does it in does it just
instantly die? We don't know. Can we
find We do not. Is there any way for us
to check? Maybe.
Can't think of any. I also don't know if
I'm handling this reference counting
stuff.
Every time map file gets called, it's
creating a new 100 array, right? So it's
not like
it's continuously loading on top of each
other
and then it gets
And we've printed out the whole agent
offsets before and it it got all of
them. So
it has to have done it initialized all
of them once before. It's initialized
them all eight times, right?
Huh? It's initialized all the maps eight
times.
Why is it doing that though? Well, why
eight times? Well, it's going to be 16
times. It's 16 workers.
I have it in serial, so just do it in a
loop.
If if you switched workers to eight and
eight, does it work? I don't
know. I can see if we switch it to one
if it works.
way. It says we're on this
unpack of numb M's.
That's where it's dying. Well, I don't
know if this is actually accurate. This
PI unic code from format V
Um, there's no way. There's just no way,
right?
Okay. So, we still get a seg. Well, it
gets farther
though. Is that consistent?
I I read about um apparently
autocompletes there's like a breaking
underscore or like a breaking what? Like
a breaking dash. Dude, no [ __ ] way.
Really? Yeah. That like LLMs like to
use. I doubted that's what's happened.
There's like no
way with that would be disgusting to if
that's if that's [ __ ] it. We're
deleting all language models and they're
banned from puffer lib editing
permanently.
Do you see this is why I just wanted to
use regular Vim and never use the Neo
Vim. Ah, you can use Neovim without the
autocomplete to be fair.
I doubt it's the problem, but if it is,
I'm that'll be insane. the machine. That
would be insane,
right? Hey, you have freaking cursor
installed. Okay.
Hey, but at least it doesn't like I
don't know. I feel like Neil Vim takes a
little bit more liberties. No, it
doesn't. You still have like you have
shitty models on that like
Okay, so here we have M ideas.
Wait, but that's totally not right.
Those are pointers.
Okay. Yeah, they're just pointers. I
mean, you can even see how long they are
technically. One 140 and then
one. It's like however many
So,
so where did it die now? Some god awful
unknown
place in this like random inline
method. I mean, it lets you call
vectorize now.
See, it is very weird that I just
retyped numbum m and it gets farther
consistently though, right?
Yeah.
Do you imagine that was actually one of
them? I mean, I think Numms is typed in
a few places like but in the string like
it's in quotes as like the thing that
has to get unpacked in
C. I wonder if it was a different
underscore
character. Be insane.
I'm not here for this level of evil.
Is it
breaking her
yeah, apparently this is a thing and
LLM's like using it.
Dude, whatever
demon decided to create a longer or
shorter underscore. I honestly I
wouldn't be surprised if it's like
somebody has a data poisoning thing to
try to like or even the companies
themselves, right? It could try to be
like a watermarking thing, right?
Wouldn't that be funny? Oh my god. Like,
yeah, we're going to watermark code by
like making it use some random ass
character
so that people can know how much code is
created by their LLM. I I wouldn't be
surprised if it's like there's some
crazy shenanigans like that going on.
nuts. Uh, so I do
have I have a breakpoint on
step. Okay.
So it got to vectorize. It got to
vectorize of the driver M because
there's a driver M, right?
And now it gets to the reset properly.
And SE faults on reset. Okay. So it's
SEG faults on reset now. Okay. Oh, you
know
what would that I don't know how I wrote
serial but if batch size is eight then
it it might have been seg faulting on
the first reset
then hang on let's go confirm
Oh, look at that. It is. You see
that? It's cuz it's the batch size is
eight. So, it gets to the first
reset and then it freaking dies. Okay,
cool.
We figured it out. We figured out where
it is dying. Okay. So, it's dying in
reset, which means we can put a break
point in reset. H. Yes. Mhm.
So, it's not just dying randomly. It's
dying consistently at the start of
reset. It's because it's eight in
because that was the batch size.
There's a C reset
here. And we just go line 1,00. Perfect.
10,00 or dishonorable if you feel like
the code should be less than a thousand
lines which I don't think is possible.
If I can make the train file less than a
thousand lines. I'm just
file. Okay, so we did not actually get
to
here is not
good. We did not get the breaking as it
even calls reset on the Python side and
not even getting to the C. Well, or it
could be in the end binding.
Okay, the ve reset is endbinding
409 or actually that's the
I thought this was going to be a lot
easier when I said, "Let's do this." By
the way,
feel like I was not extremely confident
in this being easy. Yeah, I
know. because I knew I had to do really
jank stuff in order to get the site even
to
work. Okay, so this is 64
fault. Yeah, this my fault. Oh, dude,
that's so terrible.
Okay, a damn warning. And you call
reset. See missing a
fire. I have to actually go see how it's
even possible that it lets you call this
with the wrong [ __ ] signature.
Is it is it even is it a keyword arc? I
think it matters whether it's like a
keyword or
not. Yeah, it literally I can't I don't
think it can be a keyword
for honor and glory.
For honor and glory. Yes, you
one. That is good to know that we have
that shenanigans happening.
Dude, your to-do list was gigantic.
Most of it's done.
It
runs. How long does it take for logs?
It should be there by now. Okay, we'll
figure that one out.
fast. Arguably should be the same speed.
No, 400 something. I don't
Yeah, that's my bad.
I at least I catch that one fast.
That's my
Ah, and you see it didn't rebuild it.
You see that? Mhm.
Has only the binding changed and not the
uh the actual source. I mean only the
source changed, not the binding.
right. Okie do. New binding in.
All right. Give me a second. I will be
back. I'm getting a
drink. Good [ __ ]
Okay. Did it do anything?
It's uh it went down and now it's on its
way back up. So, it matches. I mean,
that's what we
expect. See if it's does what we expect
it to do. Is this the same training
speed as before?
Yeah. 400 something.
Well, 1% of times 1% of
time. I mean, ideally I we don't have to
use 16 workers to get there, but I guess
that that's the
way.
Ideally, I mean, we can try with eight
and stuff
after. Um, it would actually let us
fewer workers lets us use more maps as
well, which is
good. And actually, when you do um, if
you do the thing I suggest where you
like cut to a specific number of maps,
we can use random maps per worker
It looks like it's going. It'll probably
cap out at it.
So, okay, we'll confirm this and then uh
you know, the original reason for all
this was that we were trying to figure
out what's happening with the
uh there was like some weird thing that
was like the first two maps being the
same.
Oh yeah.
So we can go check on that. That was
like the original problem. Now we can
put a break point in there and we can
diss we can determine that right where
the first two agents being the
same. Oh yeah, that's what we started on
hours
ago. To be fair, we did get the binding
to work and now we have GPU drive
binding.
Mhm. So that's really
nice. And now you can go flex that on
captain so he actually does the impulse
wars one.
I mean I don't know if there's much I
can flex on captain. This was 85% maybe
95% you and 5% me. Yeah, you can flex it
anyways.
The captain is so easy. I did it all by
myself in in two hours. It's no big
deal. Exactly.
cluster. I wonder if that underscore was
actually a different
character. It's unlikely, but it would
be so
funny. I mean, the actual issue was the
seed thing, right? On reset. That's my
bad.
company? This is literally just like all
the people from one of my random group
DMs.
Is this Jonathan's new game? This looks
cool. What is
this? Looks
cool. Okay. So, this trains I think
we're good. Do we call this? And uh here
I think that was successful. I mean it
it gets to it's climbing. Okay. You may
go commit this now and then we will uh
start on the other bit of the work. Yes,
do
commit. Much work was accomplished on
this and that whole Syon file gets to go
away now.
True. True. So we deleted like 20 some
odd lines from uh the environment file
and we delete the entire Syon file and
we have a much shorter binding file. All
right. So I'm going to formally remove
the Syon file.
Goodbye Satan.
No. Wait. Okay. Careful. What? Yeah. I
just want to make sure you don't
accidentally remove something we need.
It's a dangerous thing to not to be
removing [ __ ] before you've committed
the changes.
Skill.
I
mean, all I'm saying is if you if you
lose it, you're redoing it.
Fair.
All right. Um, we're not we didn't touch
setup.py meaningfully, right? We were
just commenting things in and out or
just get this stuff in there for now. I
just just I don't care. Just get this in
there so that we don't have things
break.
Uh, no. I just wanted to have it push
for now so that we can Let's fix the
other stuff.
Okay.
So, you will actually be able to PR this
cuz we didn't break anything.
True, true, true. Isn't that great?
All right, but do you want to let's PR
it after we get the new let's figure out
let's go check some data.
All
right. All right. Well, now that things
actually work, you can go put a break
point in data. Yeah. All
right. Let's go
stop. I should have gotten a wireless
one of these so I could just like Yeah,
you go do that. I'm busy doing whatever
the hell exercise.
So there's no demo that apply. So it's
always clean puff for now. Yeah, clean
puff for all has. And if you run w like
word count on it, it's under a thousand
lines of actual code for everything in
there.
Anger.
Why? Oh, I'm going to switch to
native.
Could be a
end back end
capital. No, no, not that capital. That
that lower than the actual back end.
Yeah.
Do you not like doing native anymore? Is
that like banned from life? No, I just I
think I broke things and I haven't
messed with it in a bit.
Oh, we've had a surprising number of
people that have enjoyed watching two
hours of debugging
horrendous low-level stuff. To be fair,
almost every environment has literally
just been like binding file, write 20
lines, close,
done. This one is because of the shared
initialization and stuff, which most
don't
need. Uh, it looks like the fifth one is
the same one as the third
one, and the first and the second are
identical.
The fifth one is what?
The fifth and the third are the same and
the first and the second are the same.
You're misreading that.
No, I think you're misreading
that. There you
go. Text is wrapped on your
screen. Yeah.
I think it's the same dude. What?
Look. See? Two and four are the same.
Two and four are the same. Yeah. Well,
zero zero and one are the same as well.
I know, but I'm just saying that's
another thing that's weird.
Oh, like
I don't think they should be the same.
Okay. Well, breakpoint and compute
observations time.
serial back end break point at start of
comput
ops. But let me
Oh, so this is the new thing I can do
now, right? So it's if I
All right. So what is this? GDB- args.
And then I run the thing.
PDP- args and then you run your Python.
But you just put PDP- args in front of
your Python command.
Yeah. And then from here I do what?
Break or B?
And then the line number and the file
the full file path and the line number.
No dashes or anything. Just file name,
line number, colon 888.
Mhm.
Okay.
Um,
what? I get that on my machine
sometimes. Um, but it it it's like an
intermittent thing and it just goes away
if you run it a couple times. It's like
an OS permission [ __ ] thing. Try
again. I guess that's bizaro.
Run starting program. See the You didn't
run Python. You You missed Python. Oh,
I'm an idiot.
Yeah, it doesn't. Okay. An idiot thing.
All right.
Wait, how do you have to rebuild? Huh?
Why? Why would you have to rebuild?
Because I put a breakpoint in the C in
the C in the in theh file.
No, it's the breakpoint isn't in the
source.
Yeah, it is.
No, it isn't. The breakpoint is
configured through
GDP. It's not like, you know, you you
can put break points. Go and type a
breakpoint, but like it's configured
through it.
So, it should just stop at line 88, but
clearly it's just punching through.
Okay, let me let me do it.
Fine. Yeah. Give give.
called? It has to get called, right? It
has to get called otherwise nothing
would be happening.
Okay.
Active
out.
Ah, optimized out. So, we need to
freaking compile this stuff without all
these optimizations, I
one. So there are multiple agents. Yes.
In the first level, I think there should
only be two.
Okay, let's
see. Yeah, and then we get to the start
of the function. So, there are
two. We do see two. Let's let's uh fix
our debugging
experience. Wait, is that even right?
Should there be
two? Technically, that should be map
0000.bin, right? Mhm.
Um, I'm gonna lo I'm gonna locally
render that real quick while you're
doing
that. I'm suspicious of there being
actually two
cars. Now it's not optimized out anymore
and we can actually see
things. Active agent count is
two and map name is
should be 00.
I don't know if this is just not
printing correctly
though. It says map name
equals. This was rendering the uh the
text correctly before. So that's weird.
I think I did something weird in Syon to
address
that. Ego
entity is entities of
I. Do they all start with the same
heading or something?
Do they all start with the same heading?
No, it's based on whatever the
trajectory that they were given what
spawn
points to the same
address for index zero and
entities. Where's this other
car? When I load the map, I don't see
this other car.
When I render it, this other car is
nowhere to be
found. Um,
active agent entities.
Oh, I wonder if I know what this bug is.
Okay, I have an idea.
It's in set active agents I
think and
and Okay, hold up. Let me think about
how I fix
this. Hello to all the Twitch
folks. because the first So the way that
they set it up is that the first
car is actually the last car because it
guarantees that the last car actually
has a path. Um cuz there's a weird
situation where you could have like you
could have technically because the max
cars are 64. Mhm. You could possibly run
into a situation where you have 64
static cars before you reach an active
car.
Okay.
So they always know that the last car is
going to be an active car. And I think I
may still be looping at second time even
though that's the only car available.
What would the impact of that be? You'd
have two of the same first car.
Oh, I mean that would do it.
But let me think about how I would
resolve such thing.
Okay, so n of active agent indices of
zero is 63 and m active agent indices of
one is also
63. So the ego obs are identical and
they're both referring to this index
63. That does seem
You have idea for fix for that? Yeah.
I'm just verifying that what happens and
see if you do something.
All right, I have an idea. Okay, go into
theh file or I I can probably do this.
Yeah, go ahead. I'm gonna I'll go use
the restroom real quick. I'll be back in
a minute and then I've got hour and a
half before dinner. Okay, we'll see what
gets done.
Don't let me forget to unmute.
Good. Uh, new. So, fix that, which leads
to a batch size bug because the numbum
agents is different.
Uh-huh. Um,
agent is 480.
Okay. So, that's not a good number. I
don't like that number. So, it should be
480 versus 592.
Okay. Can you get it?
Um, keep incrementing until it like up
to 512 but not
it. You just want to up the levels till
it's above 592. So, you're going to go
to like a little bit
higher on input size or numms m. Well,
it's
both four. What would you say it was
before?
I thought it was 48. The wrong the wrong
number was 592 like from the bug after
the bug has been addressed.
It was 592 before.
Is that what it was 592 before? It was
592.
This just didn't you modified the input
size, not the
um that's what I was Oh, okay. Yeah. Me
dumb.
I need to take out the break point,
but it's too big.
probably 72. Are you trying to get this
to be exactly 512?
close
seven. One more.
So not
this 72 is the
number. What was it? 510 before
something. It was 592
before. The new number is
480. Or I guess now I guess now you just
changed it to five. Whatever.
Five to
07 times
64*
So that's a big chunk of data that was
worthless. It's a big chunk of worthless
data.
So that may have been the reason why it
was learning nothing.
Then what did we do for mini batch size?
It's 256.
I think this stays the
puffer want to take out the break point.
Oh
Different one. They're taking their
time. The other
one. Oh.
bandage size of tensor
uh must
match. Why does my fly paper keep
falling down? It's disgusting. Hang
Let me just tell him anytime next week
that he that works.
All
right. Banded size of tensor.
Oh, you had your headphones on. Uh, do
you want me to just tell them anytime
that works next week?
EST. Any reasonable time?
My family as well. Okay. He's Yeah, he's
Mhm. And uh, anything on Friday?
No. Um, let
me check in with that. Many things to
check. I'll set a reminder to call in
this
evening. They said they have a bunch of
demos going on right now.
You can have one more demo with puffer
lip.
Exactly.
Expanded size. What? What do we screw up
here?
Oh, I just I just like totally messed up
for no apparent
Okay.
All right. So now this is actually
training looks like a reasonable pace.
450,000 steps per second.
Now we need now we need to figure out if
that's only one of the data issues. Oh,
of course. But let's see if this
actually does anything of
interest initially.
code. It's going to be fun once we have
all the machines for all the
experiments.
Yeah, it'll be
cool. for all the open source research.
Maybe if this actually is just worse.
Feels bad.
This is going back up. This is like the
curve that we expect. I don't know why
it goes down. Like that seems weird.
That seems like bad hypers or
whatever. We could technically try the
um I did a grid sweep. We could try the
grid parameters on
this. Okay. That would be a nice next
thing to
try cuz that like we did really really
well on that and it's kind of a similar
Yeah, it's basically the same problem
but you just get punished a little
harder.
I mean look at uh look at these hyper
prams
though. This is Are they pretty
different from the prams on default? I
mean look at them. Oh, sorry. I'm
looking I'm typing out the email. Okay,
you're good.
a female.
So that
versus Okay, I think that one's the high
gamma,
right? Or did we did we change the gamma
in this one?
Uh, this one was 98 gamma for Okay,
fine.
Wait, who is this
guy? I don't I've never heard this guy
before, but like I had somebody DM me
that they helped this guy get into the
news or
whatever. I I don't know if it's just
like they're farming. They can't even
see your likes, but like are they just
seeing like if you comment on specific
posts and like, "Oh yeah, we helped so
and so get into the news or whatever."
Let's see how this thing's
going. It's kind of following the exact
same. Well, what were the ghost cars
doing before?
right. You had like ghost cars. So, what
were they doing? You have a You would
have a ghost car
that is exactly on top of another car.
They collide. Is it registering success?
Is it like
arguably it should be
colliding at all steps, but that was not
what it was indicating.
The car in the first map was always
colliding, but it might have just been
because it was crashing.
No, I'm saying like it should have been
red at all times if technically there
was a car on top of it.
Okay, so this is like not meaningfully
different despite having fixed what
would have seemed like a major bug. Yes.
Oh, don't you love it when that happens?
All right, let's do we've killed this,
but this the other one I think got hung
at some point. So, this one does seem to
at least increase. All right. Uh I think
this is at least back to a reasonable
position. We're doing this now.
Okay.
Don't need this one.
Already
set
this tiny mini batch size. A little
weird.
We'll do this and
then I will see if we have any other
good params.
file contains no section headers
at the top. At the very top, you have a
How do I do that?
So this is number one trial. Number two
is going to
be dependent on what results we have
over
here. I have in fact been running a
sweep this entire time.
planned from the start. I hope this at
least continuously goes up.
ask. I don't know why it's starting at 0
either. So, best
breakout is sub 20 second solve
breakout.
Okay,
we got sub 20.
Yo, ridiculous honestly. First sub
Okay. So, that's got to be I mean that's
soda. So, what about
this? Yeah, that's uh you could say
that's pretty good.
You could say that that's pretty
freaking
Holy. Does grid also dump at the
beginning? Did
it maybe a little
bit? Well, there's a good reason for
that one.
Yeah, I'm still suspicious of like All
right, so let's see what we what we're
doing
here. I'll let this run a little bit.
This one's a slow config, though.
curious. It must have messed with the
clip
coefficients. Oh yeah.
Okay. That's a clip coefficient right
and.3 clip coefficient on
PO. So on your new sweeps, are you
sweeping everything including the Atom
betas and such? We are doing lots of
sweeps.
Okay. Oh, there you go. the RL results
obtained
live. I'm going to start copying these
over to my local grid
because it's going to be freaking This
is a faster run as well than the one
before. Just faster, better.
good. I bet this is going to have some
fun data as
well. You know, this whole
sweep. I'm really happy I made this grid
end. Like I spent a few days doing it,
but was
like totally worth it.
How's this going? Is it raining yet? I
don't know. You look You have access to
that one, don't you?
Yeah, it's it it fell out of its trough
and now it's climbing again, but it's
seemingly like pretty much the same.
Okay. Well, we'll give you the god
parameters.
So, what's up with n being a fixed
number?
What? What do you mean? N n in the logs.
Uh, it's fixed because you're always
collecting the exact same number of
rollouts because you have a fixed roll
out length.
This is 201 million. What is this?
200 1 million time steps. So, this does
it faster and more sample efficient than
before.
So, this is kind of funny because this
is like one of those benchmarks where
it's like, why would you even bother
trying to solve this when you can solve
like real world problems so much more
easily than this? But we solve it
anyways.
Well, now it makes me feel like there
has to be another data issue in the GPU
drive one. Yeah. Let me see if this
replicates.
Wonder how fast this
brings. Yo, we fast as
[ __ ] Okay, 1.5 mil step per second.
going to be a twominut uh twominut soda
right
here. I'm gonna send this to Aaron. He's
going to just lose his [ __ ] because he's
like there's so much curriculum learning
on this
thing. Of course, I think it'll stack so
like it'll do even better. But it's
still funny.
better. Yeah, this thing's been better.
This thing's better in a minute than
we've had previously like working at
all.
Jeez. Now, there's no guarantee that the
hypers transfer one to like just
transfer zero shot, but um this is the
exact size network that you have. So,
decent chance.
I think I after this I'm going to run a
real quick test just to make sure that
the logging is as it should be because
if I switch everything to move as expert
it should immediately go to 100% and if
it doesn't then there's something
screwed. Good idea.
This is like actual legit
experimentation now at over a million a
second because this is like this is a 2
million parameter model. This is a 512
hidden dim. This is not
like this is now like on the same like
this is the size that of people were
using for Atari models were like single
digit low single digit millions
second. Okay. So we
get
82. Let's not fully
replicate. Pretty close. They got 86 and
I get
83. I got
whatever. Let me make sure I didn't miss
a param.
Very close. All right. I think I'm going
to cancel this experiment.
Okay. Well, I will give you these
params.
It's still at like 33% which is just
like not acceptable at 177
million.
Also, the speed dropped. Oh, because
update evoxes, too. I'm giving you new
params in a second here.
Yeah. Here, I'm I'm going to kill this
and then let me uh check out the what
should be optimal performance
automatically.
I will let you do that and then we will
run the next
experiment and we'll see if it does
anything different. So I got to run d
force now every time.
What when I uh rebuild recompile the
source
probably but that's going to recompile
everything.
That's fine. easier to just like remove
the one binding like the one compiled
binding file.
It's like a two second difference in my
life. All right. Please tell me this at
least gets to
100%. All right. Yeah. So, Perf does
100% automatic when Move Expert is on.
So, it does still have off-road rates
and collision rates, which is a little
bit suspect, but
It at least is recognizing getting to
the goal with 100% rate.
So logging is still correct.
Are we ready for the parameters then?
Yep. I'm just putting it back.
So we do have to slightly modify the
batch I
believe to
Okay, let's see if this insta
solves. Let's see if this reinforcement
learns everything.
And if not, we go yell at me about data
issues. Probably.
Oh, that's right. Cuz you took over
before it uh finished.
I have Perf 1.0. It's immediately
solved.
Yes. Yes.
Very big brain. Yes. Yes. Oh, Tyler is
still here comments and stuff
periodically. Hey, how's it going?
It is fast.
450k. It's better than I had before at
100 something.
So, and this is with like all possible
ops. We need a million step per second
training though.
We actually do kind of need million step
per second training because the thing is
their initial paper claimed million step
per second training and was off by a
factor of 20.
So the goal is going to be give them
actual million step per second training.
You're like here you go. I don't think
that's possible without cutting the obs.
We are allowed to cut the ops
Yeah, I know for a fact cutting OBS on
the roads in half immediately gets you
like 200,000 steps per second on M time.
I don't know how well that translates to
training time. Well, I can tell you I
have the same exact size model that you
have training 3x faster on a grid,
right? But grid's ob size is what?
Peanuts.
Time to work on uh shelling shelling
some peanuts then.
Like what is the grid op size? Is is it
the whole map? No, it's like 11 by 11.
cuz it's only been up for like two
minutes and we're almost back at point4.
I am giving you the best possible
reinforcement learning.
Like I'm giving you the best possible
reinforcement learning other than having
to run your own sweep on GPU drive,
which you probably should do anyways.
Um, but I think from here we look for
data issues.
Oh, but it's it's doing. Oh, unless
unless I just
solve do
go. Oh, it's
better. It's better. There's no
question. It's better. Now, let's see if
it stops. But
we'll I swear to God if this just god
solves
it for
50k. If this does just go solve it. I
mean, this is the puffer advantage,
right?
Damn. I swear.
I mean, it's like if I'm setting soda on
everything and it doesn't work on your
pretty simple problem, your simple
problem is wrong, right?
You'd think so. At the least, that's a
massive improvement over the previous
one. Yes. It's at least a 50%
improvement over the previous version.
So then here's what we do now. We get
this policy and we look at it and see
what it's doing. Yeah. And then we
actually look for identifiable error
classes.
I don't think I did one beyond this one
though. That's okay. We'll do that
again. But it still has the policy
anyways,
right? You still have the policy on this
box. Yeah, I guess I have to I can SCP
it or whatever. What you do is you copy
the policy out of the folder. So you
copy it into the Docker folder because
that's mounted and then you SCP it from
there.
So you're saying take it out of Docker.
All you have to do to take it out of
Docker is just copy it to the
buffer/puffer tanker that location
because that like that directory is
mounted.
Okay. So now, mind you, it's like it's
possible that at the end because cosign
and kneeling goes crazy with your
learning rate. Like it's possible
there's some things, but we we got it to
like 58 midway through.
Um, I'm going to go do a set. I'll be
right back. Yeah, it's only five minutes
round. It's not a big deal.
The off-road rate is really low, but the
collision rate is kind of
high. Weird.
Yeah, it looks like it's failing at this
point.
That's okay. I mean, these are params
are not optimized for this, right? I got
them. These are for grid.
But it is better. I mean, we
totally we totally got way
better. Do you want me to just kill this
and rerun it with less steps? Yeah.
Should make it like 100 million or
something? Yeah. And we'll see if
um the analing might mess with it a
little bit, but we'll see. Oh, that's if
that's true, but I don't know. I don't
know if it's going to work without it,
though. So, we'll try that. We'll get a
policy. We'll get this thing running.
I'm super happy though with these
results. Like, holy.
Let's see what happens. Hey, look at
this freaking sweep.
Oh, dra not exist yet anymore. Neptune.
That hasn't existed for a while.
Well, it shows you what version of dev I
was on.
Fast moving
puffer. Closeing puffer. Does this save
uh weights now to Neptune or is that not
in release yet?
Nope. Haven't done that yet.
All right. I got to change it in clean
puffer, I think.
Too much entropy kills maze runs.
Oh, wait. No, I know where it is. It's
in a It's in default now, right? Yeah.
work. Yeah, there is a correlation with
the priorities the pryo coefficients.
Now looks like
Excuse
fast. What the
hell? I just did
this. Does it think it's on a different
project? I just changed it.
If I change clean up RL, do I have to
recompile? No.
Or that way. I only changed the config
too. Let's try
maze. I mean, I think I see it. Yeah, I
see it.
But it's like doing high level
backtracking though. That's like good 20
step
Holy. Yeah, this thing is good. This is
a ridiculously good maid solving agent
for like Tabularasa RL.
Okay. Freaking ludicrously good maze
agent. Did you hard force your Neptune
credentials anywhere?
Uh, I just paste them in like I just
export them as an N variable whenever I
need to.
No, I know. That's what I normally do,
too.
But oh my, look at this freaking maze
agent.
Holy. It still doesn't have
like It needs a pretty long
memory to
um Yeah, it would need a pretty long
memory to be fair. I don't think I could
do this task by the way with um the
vision perspective it has. I would have
to like follow the left wall or
something.
Like this thing only sees like five
tiles to either side and then it has to
remember where it's
been. I don't think I could solve this
under those constraints without like
using, you know, the left wall
rule or right wall pick a wall. Doesn't
matter. And like nobody just does that
either. You're told that that works.
And like it literally only works because
of an assumption on the way maze
generation is usually
done. Like you can make a cord maze in
which that won't even
work. Weird that does it does get hard
stuck
sometimes. Oh
no. Guess I just won't use Neptune right
now.
That does look like a
bug. Looks like there's like a rare,
very rare edge case bug.
does. It's a hard maze.
Sometimes the ones that are
um like the smaller mazes can be just as
hard if not
bug. I don't know if it's an end bug or
like the policy logic's exploding
though.
Full maze solving
agent. Very
nice mazes.
there. And hopefully we will uh at least
get a little bit of stuff done before I
got to go for dinner.
Yeah, I also progress at the same time.
See if it gets to 60 or
not. I'm most hungry.
Okay, so that's a 58 center. Wait for it
to finish.
Evvel 58 flat.
Okay, you can go ahead and grab the uh
grab that policy.
What is this again? It's an experiment
and
then Oh [ __ ]
Uh oh. What's this? What's the syntax
for this again? It's like
negative1 W or something. You get the
most recent one that popped up. What's
that? What's the full screen key?
Wait, what's the full screen key?
The full screen key. Yeah, dude. I F11.
I don't know. F11. Oh, yeah, it is.
Bye.
Oh, what's the thing again for this? Do
you remember? SCP.
No, no, not that. The most recent
experiment. It's
LS-LT experiments. Pipe head.
Uh uh like call it like move it to like
puffer tanker GPU drive.pt.
All right. Puffer tank docker. You said
GPU drive
and then just and then uh Okay. Get out
of the container now.
container here. I'll do it.
I press exit enough times and I'll be
out of it. So, home puffer puffer
tank. Home
puffer puffer
tank. Okay, so that
worked. This SCP,
you're rendering it now on your side.
[Music]
Probably should get rid of the ghost
cars in this.
Oh, do you know how to fix it for the
ghost cars?
Uh, I mean, we didn't PR any of the
stuff we did, right?
No, I can right now.
Hold
on. If it works first.
I doubt it's going to because the agent
counts are going to be different.
It runs.
Okay. Some of these guys are getting
there. Others are just ramming straight
into walls.
Yeah. So
presumably also the expert is going
through a wall,
right? Yeah, that expert can go through
a wall and it's not considered a
collision.
Most of the cars are kind of just going
straight.
So definitely PR everything so we make
sure we're not just looking at garbage.
But probably this is
correct. The question is like why the
hell is it doing this?
I thought the first scene only has uh
like two agents that are human
controlled.
It does. You're not on Are you on the
first scene? Oh, I guess this is some
random scene.
You running local or you running eval?
You're running EVO? Eval. Yeah.
The expert going through the wall. Like
that wall looks like it's a parking lot.
Not a not a wall.
Or maybe it's like a line where it's
like, "Hey, dish the entrance to the
parking lot if you care about that."
Technically, it's a road edge. And then
although currents aren't drawn,
currently it's not drawn. Um, I could
add like the other like road lines and
lanes, which the model at the moment is
technically seeing.
I see. So, we could make this pretty
freaking cool looking is what you're
saying. Yeah. I mean, you could add like
yellow lanes, lines, or whatever, and
all those types of things and like the
driveways. Okay. When we get superhuman
driving model, we get to take a little
bit of time to make Tokyo Puff look or
Tokyo Puff or whatever.
Well, I don't know about loading loading
the Tokyo map. It might be hard, but
make these maps look freaking cool is a
good start.
Let's say make it look good and then for
at least to pass it off and then we can
take it on from there to go do like
Carla or the other levels or you
know. Um, okay. So, get puffer drive
acquired for a billion dollars.
Exactly.
Puffer driving sim.
Most realistic driving sim out there. I
mean, fastest driving sim out there.
Maybe
be that'd be cool. I could put a second
one of these warehouses and fill it
entirely with
GPUs. All right.
[Music]
Um, am I in the release branch? Is that
right? All right. I'm pring my this into
the release branch.
all
right. PR's in six files changed.
How many lines? miners were cut from GPU
drive.h like 100.
Well, 250 gone from the Syon obviously.
Yeah.
100 looks like 100. Cool.
It's pretty good.
I still feel like a better obset would
just to be like do
comms, but
yes, that would be a better thing to
Did you already merge the PR or is that
uh trying to make another PR?
Well, you got to get it to me somehow.
No, I just didn't didn't know if you did
you catch that before merging it. No, I
merged it. Okay.
Okay. Isn't that nice? Now it's up to
date with the new Puffer API.
arguments. Oh, you have you can pass it
an index and it'll actually render that
M now, which is kind of cool. I forgot I
did
that. So, that's kind of nice, right?
Index
now. Uh, it's an arg render.
So I can pass like zero and I get the
first N.
Oh, okay. Got you.
Cool. Look at this awesome driving
performance.
Go. I feel like that's a super simple
one that should be able to figure out.
Yeah, I think that that's a data
problem because we had better policies
than this or right. Yeah. Yeah. Data
problem.
Oh, let's one.
Oh, have you seen what happens when you
hold shift? You can see like all the
lasers fly away.
That's cool.
So that's my rendering of its
observations. So like that's the part
where I feel like the data being wrong
is like confusing to me. But obviously
something must be wrong
and it can see the goal. Mhm.
They are also colliding with [ __ ] that
they can
see. Rewards could be wrong.
I mean yeah I mean there could be a host
of things that are wrong but memory
could be
corrupted. Puffer could be uninflated.
I don't know. PG puffer.
Let's see if we can make any progress
next. Yeah. The problem is not hard
enough where it shouldn't be able just
to solve. No. Yeah. Once we fix this,
it's going to be like boop. Problem
solved in 40 mil. Well, that was
trivial.
Yeah. It just has to
Uh, with the new
binding, I don't see any reason why not,
right? We can totally do that, right?
You should just only have to change num
ms in config. I think
I don't think we hard set anything in
the binding. I was going to say that we
just make the map index or yeah envid in
the in GPU drive, right? Because envid
is just
we can pass in we can actually just in
the GPU drive.py set env ID to always be
a zero.
So that you have 75 or however many
lap. Okay. Apparently this somehow
trains
I'm suspicious of this training because
it goes to
We're going to debug this. Is it going
to work
today? 507.
What? Oh, because Yeah, I I
trolled cuz it's this agent offset
thing. Yeah.
So we have to do kind of like the jank
version
the cloning way I did it before. Well, I
think it's like num
m num m is
one and vec numb n numb n numb n numb n
numb n numb n numb n numb n numb n numb n numbum workers is 16 and num m is
n numbum workers is 16 and num m is
going to be
like
4096 like 20
48 and then we can actually
wrong. So, it's going to be what?
Um 8192 *
256. That's too
cereal. Mini batch must be divisible by
horizon. That's true. Yeah, that's true.
Okay, this
is an absolutely freaking trivial
problem.
think it doesn't collide. It just
doesn't do. It's decided to do nothing.
It's decided to give up.
It said honorable Sepoku is the only
way.
You seeing this [ __ ]
Oh, it went up. I got rid of the
collision penalties.
We're going to do 20 million steps or
even 15 million
steps and it's going to solve
it and then it's going to be
Well, turning collisions off is like not
like a great Well, they're not off
anymore. It resets it on collision,
remember?
Well, yeah, it resets it, but you don't
get It like has no idea why it got
reset.
Well,
instead. Okay, it does actually just egg
bault.
Can we
uh do we have any ideas on why? Oh, I
know why actually. Okay, I know why.
That's why
is Whoa. Look at this.
trying.
It's trying. I only trained at 20 mil
steps, but it actually does a thing
now. It actually does roughly what you
would hope it does. It should
do. I don't know why it's like spazzing
at sometimes,
but I mean, it was only 20 million
steps. Not
even. You do 30 mil next. 30.
It was 15. No, I'm saying yeah, go 30.
I got to go whenever dinner is served.
That that works out for me. I I have
dinner thing as well. We're going to get
a couple more experiments and maybe get
some good models. So, while this is
training, since I have a minute and we
do have quite a few folks on Twitch,
let's take a quick look at the puffer
star count. Did we hit 2K?
One more star. Come on. Somebody there
has to have not started. Somebody's got
to come through for
2K. But anyways, all my stuff is uh free
and open source right here on
puffer.ai. I do this pretty much every
single day. Um you want to help me out,
start the GitHub. If you want to get
involved in development of this, build
ultra high performance reinforcement
learning M, get into AI, help advance
AI, any of that stuff, some of our top
contributors came in with zero AI
experience whatsoever, so it can be
learned. Join the Discord for that.
Other than that, you can follow me on X
for more RL content. I'll be
here for a few more minutes and then I
will probably be back after dinner for a
little bit, depending. If not, I will
definitely be back in the morning.
Okay. So, this is full solved. Yeah.
So, there is one more experiment. I want
to
run. One more.
Okay. Are you just going to do the same
same concept but with more levels? Of
course.
That works, right? It no longer looks
like it's insane. That's like a
reasonable turn radius.
Wait, is there undo in Neoam?
Yes. Wait, do not
you. And there's redo as well. Capital
R.
Oh, that's so legit. Wait, is it capital
R?
Yeah, capital R. I know it intuitively,
right? I actually have to like do it to
know what it
is. That's so weird that that can
happen. Your muscle memory is just Yeah.
Like I know I know intuitively how to do
it, but if I think about it, I don't
know what the key is.
I actually think that um Neoim is why I
kind of type wrong if you think about it
because it's
HJKL. So if you think about it, your
hands shift over a whole position to the
left on the keyboard,
right? I mean, I don't use any if why
would you be using
HJKL versus something else?
That's navigation in Vim.
Dude, I just use backslash to get me to
everywhere. I just search everything.
You're screwing with me.
I search and press N. Nah, you're screw
you're screwing with me. Nah. Nah,
you're trolling. You're freaking
trolling. You do not do that [ __ ]
You're trolling. You're such trolling.
Do you don't believe my efficiency of
building M comes from pressing search
bar?
If it is, you could be building them a
fair bit faster, I'll
say. Okay. So, there isn't a weird dip
at the start
anymore. Not really.
I wouldn't consider that first thing to
be a relevant dip. It's not like Well,
this is what it used to look like.
No, that's what I'm saying. Like the I'm
saying that the dip at the start of the
new curve. I mean, that could be just
like noise from like being alive for 0.1
seconds.
Uh, it is only run for 100 mil though.
That's fine. We'll see how how well it
does in that time frame.
You can make it 250 or 500 or whatever.
So if I get this to work then with this
or if this like works at least
substantially
better
then it's going to be
sweep the hyper
pram
including the nth reward
coefficients
right yeah I guess.75 is too aggressive
we'll sweep
But do you want to sweep with the new
sweep with current params fixed and then
reward? No, just sweep everything or
just giga sweep everything. Giga sweep
freaking everything for uh 150 mil or
whatever time steps. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
use my defaults or whatever. So we fix
mini batch size. You fix it to fast runs
so that all the runs are like reasonably
paced and you just crank out 200
experiments overnight.
Wait, wait, wait, no, no, no. Because I
have to use the special mini batches and
batches sizes for this. So that can't be
touched. Then leave it fixed. So that
will have to be fixed and everything
else can run around. Yeah, but we have a
lot of coefficients to sweep. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. This getting hard stuck at
58 is
sus.
before.58. I thought it went a little
higher, but thought it was like
58%. It seems to have hit a
wall. Now it's sus.
We have this
model. Let's see though if we tr we
eval. And I'm going after we do this.
Yeah, that
works. And you know what to do to repro.
Ah, isn't that
funny? We train on more
M's punk into the wall.
Isn't that weird? Data issue question
mark of like assigning could be the N
could be like how the observations are
being assigned between M's could
be but we get it. It it can overfitit a
map immediately pretty much, right?
It has a weird ass like plateaus like
that that flat equals problem. It can't
learn more,
right? So, I don't
know. I'm going to get dinner. If I see
you around after dinner, we can continue
on this. Otherwise, we can do this
whenever you're free. All right. Sounds
good. Thanks. Well, thanks, Spencer.
Good progress.
Oh. Uh, did you send me anything or no?
Uh, let me check my inbox.
Nope. They haven't sent anything over. I
It would be rude to nudge him right now.
I'll nudge him. I'm not I'm not stressed
about it. Cool. All right. Sounds good.
See you, Spencer. And for all the folks
uh on Twitch, let's see if we hit
date? App's missing one star. Come on.
Somebody has to have not started.
Anyways, then I'll be back either later
tonight or tomorrow. Thanks, folks. See
you around.